hello everyone and welcome to bloodline
the taxonomy of fear where we examined
what if anything makes a movie scary yes
and this week we have a very special
opportunity to examine the scope of the
mega franchise these don't come along
very often and not really ever I mean
I've been off since the mid 70s early
80s when they started coming out when
the Four Horsemen of Hell were born your
Freddie you're Jason you're Michael and
what I'm going to say is the most
venerable of all for Leatherface who is
back in texas chainsaw massacre 3d and
doing surprisingly well in the box
office and so this is going to give us
an opportunity to look at that movie in
the context of these six previous movies
and we're going to use the frame you
know you're watching a texas chainsaw
massacre movie when surprised it begins
with a road trip hopefully in a van and
a van is important because you can fit
more victims in a van exel and you're
taking a road trip through texas which
could be an isolated place which is
necessary for a lot of horror movies yes
and number five exit through a window in
the first movie it is the crucial to our
protagonists when she bolts the home
going through a plate-glass window to
get away it's a huge turning point in
move yet sort of appears throughout the
other movies in the franchise as well
but not so in Texas Chainsaw 3d all
right trope number four in the Texas
Chain Saw movies a mask made out of a
human face Leatherface might be a
butcher by profession but he's he likes
to sew as a hobby bit of an atelier yes
he likes he likes to make masks stitch
together from the faces of his victims
and this is because he's horribly
disfigured and so he takes the skin of
the faces of his victims and stitches
together a mask for himself and in this
movie he not only stitches together a
mass for himself he actually shows it to
his own face next lab which was awesome
yeah I thought that was a working well
in 3d and next on the list is the
sliding metal door this is another one
of those moments that doesn't come up in
all the Texas Chain Saw movies but is so
iconic from the first one and has given
a nice nod in Texas Chainsaw 3d
that it really sort of is a metaphor for
like the entire sense of hope and
happiness that you can expect to let go
the moment it shuts when that door
closes it is over yeah life's gone
number two on the list is the
interminably long family dinner this is
where we really get a good place to be
home life of leather face and his
twisted redneck cohort but it always
drags on far too long and I was glad to
see that in Texas Chainsaw 3d they did
not reincorporate the family dinner but
did give a nice little sort of easter
egg with a breaking bread moment at one
point in the film and finally number one
indicator that is a texas chainsaw
massacre movie is the chainsaw dance the
first one ends with leather phase of
wielding his chains on in the background
the sun's coming up and he's in
silhouette and it is a crazy scary scene
and it seals him in the Canon of horror
movie villains yeah which should not
ever be replicated in the phone because
they try but they don't really succeed
yeah there's some there's some wild
wielding about but never really the
orchestral finale that yeah and in this
one in 3d there's a scene where he
throws the the saw at the camera yeah
actually duct which was kind of
embarrassing hate to admit it but but
I'm kind of glad they dispensed with
that in the new one medium this texas
chainsaw massacre 3d fit the bill of
being a texas chainsaw massacre movie
three out of the six is another not that
good but i think it's actually in the
end might be a good thing because it
indicates a new direction the franchise
is going to go into yeah it gives a nice
little retouching on the origin story
and then sort of refresh as our
relationship with Leatherface to send us
off into the one possibly six sequels
that lionsgate has the option to
exercise a whole new batch of cliche
absolutely Jordan what's yours I am
going to go with the sort of weird
stepchild that's like the side universe
of the Texas Chain Saw franchise which
is Texas Chainsaw Massacre the next
generation and it stars a incredibly
young Renee Zellweger and Matthew
McConaughey and the inspiration for the
killings that the family does is a
little bit different from the other
movies in the franchise but Eddie it's
weird enough to see even
I think it's probably the worst of all
seven interesting choice yeah I'm going
to go with texas chainsaw massacre the
beginning the origin story of leather
face in this family because it provides
a nice arc for the recent movie which
actually goes into making him a somewhat
sympathetic character but god Dale
remember what we did so that's it for
this episode of bloodline email us at
bloodline at wired.com let us know what
you think we'd like to hear from you and
as we like to say here at bloodline
remember she's just a movie